[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Tulku Lobsang is
a Buddhist master, doctor
of Tibetan medicine, and
purveyor of transformation,
student of Dalai Lama, winner
of 14th Dalai Lama Award
of Excellence in Health
and Spirituality.
He has reached the high level
of rinpoche and incarnate Lama.
His teachings are
mostly related to wealth
of body, mind, and life.
He is frequently wanted for
giving talks and workshops
at European business
schools and companies.
His teachings apply to Buddhist
psychology and Tibetan medicine
techniques to influence
authentically [INAUDIBLE],,
diversity in the workforce, and
freeing oneself from burnout.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Tulku.
And I will give you a massive
thank you for coming to here.
Thank you very much.
TULKU LOBSANG: I think our
main subject today is how
the burnout--
correct?
I think that is
the main subject.
Maybe I say this way first.
In the Buddhist
tradition, relaxation
is the wisdom without learning.
Relaxation is become
medicine without doctor.
But in this modern
world, relaxation
we don't have so
much higher value.
We think relaxation
means nothing important.
But relaxation have many
things to give in our mind,
in our body, in our life.
But they have one problem,
relaxation and laziness
is I'm used to tell same
mother and a different father.
Yes, we don't know
what we really have.
We don't know what we
are really practicing.
Many people believe they're
practicing relaxation.
But maybe we're
practicing the laziness.
And we never thought--
or we never think laziness
how much have a power.
But laziness is the
king of our life.
He make trouble, all
kind of transformation.
That's the reason Buddha
[INAUDIBLE] and he say,
laziness make you a dead
person without dying.
You're not dead, but you look
like dead because of laziness.
I'm sure many people you
say me, I'm not so lazy
person because I'm so busy.
That's possible.
But we have three
kind of laziness.
We have laziness who
don't want to do anything.
And this mean I'm
called gross laziness.
It's not so dangerous, laziness.
Everybody see you
are lazy, maybe
you also feel you are lazy.
I don't know.
And then, we have a
second kind of laziness.
And the laziness who
always want to do tomorrow.
In the Buddhism, we have
a special name this.
But I'm just using
my simple English.
Yes, laziness who always
want to do tomorrow.
And this we call
subtle laziness.
As who want to do
tomorrow is make
we have more stress than who
don't want to do anything.
Correct?
Laziness who say, I don't want
to do anything, it's a problem,
but it's not so complicated.
It's clear.
Very, very honest,
very, very authentic.
But laziness who say, I
do tomorrow, you don't--
you don't say, I
don't want to do.
But you say, I do it tomorrow.
And the second laziness we
call subtle laziness, but more
intelligent laziness.
But one of the big,
strongest laziness
what we experience this
21 century, number third.
And this is very difficult
to translate very well,
but we say laziness who always
want to do other things.
I hope we translate--
I hope I make
translate perfectly.
And the laziness who always want
to do other things, or laziness
who always need to
do other things.
But I think better
is laziness who
always want to do other things.
This name we call
great subtle laziness.
We call hidden laziness.
Nobody see you are lazy.
You also don't
believe you are lazy.
But this is a very, very
intelligent laziness.
That is the killer of our
happiness, our health,
or to make stress
and [INAUDIBLE],,
the number third laziness.
Why I talk here is
because of the relaxation.
The relaxation is, I say, is
the wisdom without learning.
Relaxation is the
medicine without doctors.
Relaxation, happiness
without reason.
Yes.
But laziness is so
near with relaxation,
we really don't
know what we have
or what we're really practicing.
Therefore, I recommend
to everyday life
to practice relaxation.
But to practice relaxation
means you don't--
I mean, relaxation does not mean
you need to do things slowly.
Sometimes people misunderstand.
Relaxing means it needs to
be slowly walk, slowly walk.
OK, that's also good.
Correct.
Or sometimes people
think relaxation means
don't do anything.
However, that's the
reason meditation
become very important.
Meditation is-- meditation
is the way to relax.
Yes, but what do
we need to relax?
What do we need to relax?
Relax our efforts.
We are a world of effort.
We are a world of the effort.
Means we are world
of the condition.
We are never free
of a condition.
No matter how you success, we
are never free of a condition.
Yes, that means we are
a world of the effort.
And this effort-- sometimes
our effort becomes force.
Force?
Effort, force,
whatever you call,
and that's make we are stress,
and burn out, or depression.
I know we are not
enlightened world.
We are a world of the condition.
Means we are a
world of the effort.
We are world of the effort means
we are world of the action.
Whatever we want to
change in this world,
somehow we need action.
But the action is not the
only way to solve things.
But without action, also your
possible things to solve.
Example, relaxation.
Therefore, what we
relax and relax effort.
But the very interesting
thing, sometimes we say relax.
I say relax.
Then mostly people
think they know relax.
But I'm very interested
in when I say relax,
what picture in your
mind, in your head?
I'm very interested in.
I say, please, relax.
What kind of a picture
comes in your mind?
Somewhere you sit,
lay down, oh, relax.
What kind of a picture is come
in your mind when I say relax?
However, what I want to
say, in my philosophy,
we believe 98 our troubles,
or 98 our problems,
the projection of your mind.
Only two problems is not
projection of your mind.
But 98-- yes, all
kind of problems--
is the projection of mind.
You relax five to 10
minutes, all this 98 problems
dissolve or disappear herself.
It's amazing.
Relaxation you
don't need to learn.
Relaxation is beyond religion.
Relaxation beyond culture.
Relaxation is beyond philosophy.
Relaxation is beyond science.
Something we never
need to learn.
What?
Relaxation.
But the problem, we don't
have anything something
we don't learn.
That is a problem.
That's the reason
I say relax, then
you start to thinking,
OK, how I do?
Because you always used to do
everything with your learning.
But something you don't need to
learn and you become nervous.
You don't believe how
possible this is a function?
And therefore, you
need to learn to relax.
And you never success to relax.
Maybe you learn everything
OK, except relaxation.
But let's say we start
to say, hello, relax.
You say, OK.
Then you start to try to relax.
You try to do relax.
You see?
I say don't do anything.
That's what I'm talking.
But you say, yes, OK, I'm trying
to relax, I'm trying to relax.
You try to relax
that is not relax.
Don't do relax.
But you see, you
don't have-- we don't
have something we not learn.
Therefore, you try to relax.
And then, you go to relax
and this make you stress.
Then many people say, I think
I'm not good with meditation.
I think so, I'm not
good with meditation.
Meditation is not function me.
I think the problem we
don't cut to the point.
Maybe I like to
say maybe this way.
Therefore, relaxation is
the medicine of all problem.
Therefore, maybe you
try to every morning--
every morning try to
have a small relaxation,
five to 10 minutes.
Each three hour, try to
remember the relaxation.
Because each three hour,
our mind start to forget it,
what we promised ourself,
or what we give instruction
ourself.
That is-- again--
What I want to say, just
a simple relaxation--
to relax you don't
need to speak English.
Really, that's a good thing?
You don't need to be Buddhism.
You don't need to speak English.
Relaxation is, I
think, maybe universal.
I mean, you don't
need to speak German,
or you don't need to
speak Tibetan to relax.
Therefore, you make-- five to 10
minutes make simple relaxation.
I just tell you the small
tips or small methods.
It's the 98 your
problems is disappear.
Look like weather of today.
Weather of today, Seattle have
very beautiful weather today.
Just all clouds
disappear, empty space.
In the similar, just after
10 minutes, after 10 minutes
or after five minutes of your
relaxation, you open your eyes.
And then, you see two problems.
After relaxation, you
don't see three problems.
Only you see two problems.
I guarantee you.
I'm just joking.
USA very much like guarantee.
I see in your
televisions always,
yes, now guarantee,
guarantee, call now,
guarantee, give
back, or something.
You always have this
kind of very much energy.
Europe you go is
nobody guarantee.
Everybody relax.
Very loud, guarantee,
I look away I
see on your
television you always
have this advertisement
somewhere you find
a way, guarantee, guarantee.
OK.
Yes, very good.
Therefore, my
conclusion is after--
after 10 to five
minutes relaxation
there are only two
problem remain.
They no have a three problem.
And this two problem is
also not really problem.
What I want to say
here, once you relax,
you only see two problem
no matter what kind of you
have problem.
What I mean this
two problem may be--
no matter what kind
of problem you have,
maybe you possible change,
maybe you no possible change.
That's all.
You possible change your
problem, it's not a problem.
problem, it looks like problem,
but really, really
not a problem.
Isn't it?
And you problem you
no possible change,
how possible something
unchangeable become
your problem?
Correct?
Well, let's-- we need to be
a little more intelligent.
Something changeable is not
really, really, really problem
because I possible change.
If something unchangeable,
how possible this
become problem you?
Let's be a little intelligent.
Cows also not take
unchangeable things a problem.
We are human beings.
Maybe we are a little more
intelligent than cows.
But I need to say
something here.
We human beings have one thing
something cows don't have.
Cow is not enough
intelligent to change others.
That's the only reason
cows why is relax.
I'm just joking.
Sometimes you look in the cows--
sometimes I go, it's
not so bad to be cow.
Sometimes you look in
their face, it's quite OK.
I'm just joking.
Cows is-- cow don't know
how to change others.
Changing others
is the main reason
why we have stress, and
burn out, depressions.
In my philosophy, changing
others is always wrong.
No matter you have right.
No matter right.
Changing others is one of the
great humans ever know to--
one of the great ever humans
possible make a mistake.
But remember, we all
possible help others.
But we no possible
change others.
And the help and the
change is very near again.
I told you before relax and
the laziness is so near,
we misunderstand similar.
We misunderstand
change and help.
Yes, we need to help others.
We also need help others.
Everybody need help until
we are in this world.
Until we are in this
world, we always need help.
You say, yes or no,
no make a different.
You always need help.
Isn't it?
We are born also with help,
not you just born yourself.
Correct?
You're just not born yourself.
In your life, also not leave,
you not just leave yourself.
You also need the
help of others.
Also, after dead,
or you're dying,
you not possible
just die yourself.
You always need help of others.
They no have a moment of we
don't need help of the others.
We always need the
help of others.
However, changing others is--
I'm used to tell people
whoever want unhappy,
please don't forget
to change others.
That's all.
You don't know how
to make unhappy?
Simple, just you
practice change others.
You don't believe me, you
try to with your girlfriend
or your boyfriend.
You just not make big change.
Maybe you have big problem,
just make small change.
Name of the help we always
try to change others.
That's the reason in my
philosophy always say,
changing others is one
of the biggest mistake
ever have in human history.
We no more how to change
others, we no more
how to make more problem.
However, what I want to
say here changing yourself
we always say wisdom.
Helping others is your power.
Helping others is your power
and the power without--
helping others is your
power, power without taking.
Power without you taking.
Whenever you need to take power
and that's make you tired.
But somehow, we need power.
We need the power
because this world,
world of the action,
action need power.
I understand.
But power you need
to receive naturally.
How?
With help.
I'm sure then what mean help?
Or I don't have so much
money, how possible
I'm helping others?
You just smile at somebody.
That's enough to help others.
You don't need to give
millions of money.
Help means you just say hello.
That's already help.
You just say smile.
It's already help.
Therefore, helping
others is your power.
Changing yourself
is your wisdom.
Helping others is
your happiness.
Then nothing have more
happiness than that.
Changing yourself is freedom.
What we need, what we want,
happiness and freedom.
Freedom is not-- freedom--
OK, I say this way, freedom
is some kind of realization.
It's not something you
possible really make, I think.
Therefore, my conclusion,
our topic today, stress
and burnout,
especially burn out--
I'm sure I give a
few other techniques.
But I just want to
tell the relaxation.
Relaxation name we call
wisdom without learning.
Therefore, please, don't
learn how to relax.
And please, don't do relax.
Don't try to relax.
Then hopefully, you
know what I mean.
And the relaxation is
not something you receive
and something you discover.
Relaxation is not
something you receive,
something you discover.
That means you
don't try to relax.
Just be.
Therefore, I'm
used to tell people
relax without make relax.
Therefore, maybe 21 minutes
practice, maybe every morning,
is your possible.
21 minutes of the
practice, maybe.
I just want to say this,
21 minutes of practice.
That's 21 minutes
of the practice.
Change is your one day.
Change over one day is
become change of your life
because life is never
come bigger than one day.
You're born one day.
You live one day.
You die one day.
Tomorrow is not exist.
It's exist, but does
not really exist.
Tomorrow never come.
Therefore, I'm used to tell
people yesterday is dead.
Tomorrow is not the born.
Today is the only what you
have, but that's enough.
Therefore, today is the day.
Today you are happy.
I call you have a happy life.
Therefore, I never tell people
try to have a happy life.
I always say try to
have a happy day.
Because life is
too long, too big.
We have confuse.
However, this life
is still 100 years.
Our body is made
to stay 100 years.
Anybody stay more than 100
years, you are illegal.
Please, don't stay.
You are illegally
stay in this planet.
After 100 years, are
against the nature.
You need to die.
I'm sorry to say this.
OK, some people I'm sure stay.
However, mother planet is
just a beautiful hotel.
I don't say this is
home, but is hotel.
Please don't act look like home.
Just act look like hotel.
Means don't try to own things
and try to just use things.
Don't try to own things.
And just try to
make enjoy things.
But sometimes humans
so much focused owning.
You try to buy, own.
Look like you stay forever.
But not in this beautiful hotel.
You not only stay 100 years.
What's 100 years?
Maybe I'm now 40 years
old, maybe we are--
maybe same age
around many people.
But after 20,000 day, I'm
nearly 90 years, or 95,
or 96 years old,
after 20,000 days.
The famous life,
life is so famous.
Everybody just be in the life.
Life is famous.
You calculate it,
it's only 20,000 days.
What do you make so complicated?
It's very important talk,
I'm sorry to say it, death.
Death makes you more
relaxed and calm.
It's not nice, but
it's good message.
Sometimes our ego is growing
so much, and then better
to think death.
And then, you come more calm
and you're more realistic.
You're more grounded.
Otherwise, sometimes
you too much fly.
Therefore, after 20,000 day,
you all, we all, is dead people.
And especially people who
don't believe in next life,
this is your last chance.
It's OK, you don't believe
in next life, very OK.
I also make some joke in Europe.
I would say, we need many people
who don't believe in next life
because that is the only
way to reduce population.
Nature way, voluntarily nobody--
you just decide yourself.
So I say, oh, very good,
we need more people who
don't believe in next
life because then we
have less human beings.
Just joking.
I'm just joking.
Let's say we have a 20,000 day.
You count yourself.
I don't think we have more
than 20,000 day mostly.
In the 20,000 day,
10,000 day we sleep.
And that's it, sleep.
And then we left 10,000 day
more and maybe 8,000 day,
or 7,000 day, we go to
work to sit on chair,
whatever chair, gold chair,
or diamond chair, is a chair.
You sit in the one chair.
And you're working.
And then you're
left the 2,000 day.
And 1,000 day maybe
you're not happy.
Or I don't know.
Then you left 1,000 day.
1,000 day means
maybe is three years.
And you need preparation
to check out in the hotel.
Mr. Death is calling
your room number
and he speaks all languages.
He never make a mistake.
He never make mistake.
Once he call your room number,
he never make a mistake.
Correct?
Let's we are guests in
one beautiful hotel.
Five star hotel, I call.
Five star hotel means the planet
made with the five elements.
They have many planets in the
space, but they have maybe--
they don't have so many
look like our planet.
I'm sure they have
countless because infinite.
Yes, we are in the best planet.
It's five star, five elements.
Therefore, let's make enjoy.
Yes, you see life is shorter
and you have less stress.
I think, me, this way,
maybe some people not.
Maybe, yes?
But however, is we
are just in the hotel.
Yes, it's a beautiful
hotel, but we are hotel.
Therefore, just relax.
Therefore, I'm used to
tell sometimes people
may be Mr. Death calling
your room number.
Then you start to say,
hey, hello, Mr. Death,
but I'm so important person.
I have so many things to do,
but please you call tomorrow.
Correct?
You possible save, but no.
And then, maybe you
say, hello, Mr. Death, I
know I'm in your hotel,
but I have much money.
I give every night
10,000 Euro gift.
Please extend my stay.
And Mr. Death is laughing
with the deep voice.
He say, ha, ha, ha.
He laughing.
He's just laughing at you.
He say, I'm sorry.
Never try again this, he say.
He say, my hotel is so
famous in this planet.
These next 100 years
already booked.
And you, tomorrow, need
to check out before 12:00.
I'm sorry.
Therefore, my conclusion,
what I want to say.
Life is short.
It's only 20,000 days.
Why are we fighting so much?
I know everybody fighting.
Fighting to look like we
need to be here forever.
Everybody worries look like
we need to stay here forever.
But it's only 20,000 day.
What you need more
than just 20,000 day?
Let's be intelligent.
But be more realistic.
Therefore, what I want to
say, every morning maybe
you try to 10 minutes
some exercise.
What kind of exercise no matter.
Any exercise or you just create
your own exercise, whatever.
The exercise
release the tensions
and the blocks of your body.
Yes, you make 10
minutes exercise.
I don't think that's
a big problem.
And then, 10 minutes
you make relaxation.
10 minutes relaxation.
After 10 minutes relaxation,
I give you two kind
of wisdom words or something.
OK, totally you need, I
would say, 21 minutes.
I think maybe I'm
a little too much,
maybe I'm [INAUDIBLE]
of the talking here.
But in the 21 minutes,
possible change your life.
I'm not saying this in Europe.
Nobody come then.
I say 21 minutes practice
change your life.
I think they don't believe me.
Sometimes I need to come
different country I need
to talk little different way.
Everybody have a
different culture.
However, 10 minutes exercise,
10 minutes relaxation.
After all of the 20 minutes, I
want you to say two sentence.
The sentence you say this way.
You open eyes.
Before you give any
action, before you
give any, any action,
mentally, verbally, physically,
before you give any
action, just you relax.
You're just calm, pure
and in the nature.
And you say this way.
First, action in
your mind, you say,
I do my best in this world.
You really not only
saying somewhere.
You really say in the
bottom of your heart.
You don't do this way.
I do my best.
Correct?
I do my best, not this way.
Or you look your iPad,
you say, I do my best.
Hello.
No, that's not
make you different.
You really relax.
Calm and you go
deep in your inside,
at the bottom of your
heart, middle of your bones,
through your blood, you
really feel the sentence.
You say, I do my best in this
world in myself or others.
Then you say, but after
whatever happen, I accept it.
I do my best, still
something go wrong.
I accept it.
In this world, world
is never go perfect.
World is never go perfect.
Never go best.
There always need
someplace to accept it.
That is the only solution.
That's name what Buddhism is
called kindness and compassion.
We do our best.
This is kindness.
After something go
wrong, we accept it.
This is compassion.
But kindness is very
near attachment.
Kindness is very
Compassion is very near
sometime sadness or anger.
Therefore, sometimes
we very easy to--
sometime we go to
practice a kindness,
we only want to practice
kindness nice people,
beautiful people.
Correct?
You're very nice.
I want to be kind.
But maybe this is not kindness.
This is attachment.
Therefore, attachment,
kindness we misunderstand.
Sometimes compassion and
sadness, compassion or sadness
or anger, we also misunderstand.
Therefore, my conclusion,
you have two simple practice.
10 minutes exercise, and
then relaxation, and then
two sentence.
The sentence you
say, I do my best.
After something go
wrong, I accept it.
That's it.
Therefore, I'm used to
tell people making joke,
you go back now home maybe
your house is going on fire,
and you don't forget to tell
your house I did my best,
but I now accept it.
House, I did your best.
But now you just
decide to go fire.
I accept it, but maybe this
not happen again, again.
I better make one picture.
You make one selfie picture,
but don't put in the Facebook.
You don't receive insurance.
Therefore, somebody ask me, some
businessman, he ask me Tuklu,
it looks like you are happy.
And you have any special
method how to be happy?
Then I just make a joke.
I have a small method, but
you don't tell anybody.
You tell this and
you lose your job.
And then he said, what is that?
I said, if you really
want to be happy,
you need to be a little crazy.
Not big crazy, OK?
We have so many crazy people,
but not completely crazy.
But be a little crazy.
Because life is crazy.
Anyway, therefore
my conclusion I
wanted to show you a small
exercise, very small exercise.
And then short relaxation
and then the sentence.
That's OK?
It's good?
Yes.
OK, the exercise is
a very, very small.
I want you to close your
fists this way and also here.
These areas, very
important areas.
However, you make somehow--
somehow you look like this way.
And the 21 seconds, I want
you all of the muscles--
faces also I want to do this.
OK, but I don't make
a picture of you.
Look like you have
pain, but without pain.
21 second and you do this.
And then, relax.
That's OK?
You are ready?
That's simple--
Sorry, before we do this I want
you to make one self massage.
Warm up your palms.
And to make- massage
is very good.
OK.
Yes, are you ready?
OK, 21 second you
make tight everything.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18,
19, is power, power, power,
together everything, together.
21 minutes, please.
21, breathe out.
I want you do this.
One time more this exercise.
OK?
With holding the breath, 21
seconds you hold the breath.
And the longest holding
this breath record
is 25 minutes officially.
But some of Tibetans,
some Indians,
they hold two day, three
days, but is not they
practice official place.
But let's say not hold
20 minutes, 25 minutes,
only just 21 seconds.
Hold your breath in the navel
and to make tight everything
again.
Because we increase
wind and the fire.
With this exercise, we increase
in the wind and the fire.
And then we'll relax.
And then we come
in earth and water.
And then all balance.
That's the secret.
Ready?
Breath breathe in.
Hold your breath.
OK, tight, 21 seconds.
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20,
full power, full power,
21 minutes, breathe out.
I think we don't need
the 10 minutes exercise.
Now we one make
breath, breathe in.
And this exercise
increase wind and fire.
Now we mix more relaxation.
We keep straight our spine.
Now we connect the
earth and the water.
Relax all of your efforts.
Just be without any effort
in your body and your mind.
You go deeper, relax.
And you discover
this inner space.
The nature of this
inner space is peace.
Thank you very much.
Then you say these two sentence.
I do my best.
After whatever
come, I accept it.
And then, you never have
a problem with life.
You know exactly how swim.
Life is look like ocean.
We are in the ocean.
We are not in the land.
The solution only swim.
I know nobody wants to
swim, but you need to swim.
But remember, to swim
we need to relax.
Otherwise, long swim.
Life is the wave of the
ocean, wave of change.
We just need to swim,
but we need to relax.
And then my last two
sentence or three sentence,
whenever you have stress or
burnout, whatever you have,
you need more energy.
We have one small solution.
The shower, shower
in my tradition
is a shower is very,
very spiritual practice.
Shower with fresh water,
not hot, not cold.
Just fresh water.
Just shower.
You stay under the water
maybe 5 to 10 minutes.
And you come out.
You don't believe
what change you have.
But the problem, we don't
believe that because too cheap,
too easy.
I'm sorry, but too
cheap and too easy.
But just shower.
Shower, give you a new
mind, new body, new life.
It's amazing.
And the second thing is you
really don't want burnout,
stress.
They have one thing you
practice everyday life.
Like people.
How many people you like?
AUDIENCE: 6 billion.
TULKU LOBSANG: 6
billion, exactly.
Therefore, practice
to like people.
Understand?
Like people, but that's not
mean all people is good.
That's nothing to do
good, or right, or wrong.
Just try to like people.
Like people because
people is the big problem.
Who make we are stress,
who make we are burnout,
maybe who make we are unhappy.
Therefore, try to like people.
Maybe you go to the
outside sometimes just
try to scream yourself
I like people.
I know you say I like trees.
Trees is good.
But the tree never make
your problem so much.
You don't like trees,
it not big, big problem.
But the people is a problem.
Therefore, we need to
practice like people.
I think this give
you more energy.
This If you more happy.
And you maybe many
good things have.
And then, my last words, whoever
want more stress, burnout,
don't forget to change others.
And thank you very much.
And I'm finished.
I think our time is
somehow finished,
but maybe I give one or
two time to have question.
Is OK?
AUDIENCE: So my
question for you is
a lot of times I
feel like when I'm
trying to do things
efficiently, which
means to do it at the shortest
amount of effort, that caused
me to be stressed or upset.
So is there something
about that, being efficient
versus happy, is there
anything about that
you will want to say?
TULKU LOBSANG: OK, I just make
a very short answer give here.
But I think it's most important
whatever you do before.
Whatever you give some actions
is very important to relax.
Once you relax, and you
see everything clear.
Once you see everything
clear, all of your actions
make different you.
But the problem we make
action first and then we think
is after.
And then, always is
we do so many things,
but very little things happen.
But then people
always think, OK, I
want to happen everything fast.
But then relax is the
opposite of happening fast.
Therefore, we know
to relax first.
And we try to action first.
But first you relax.
You relax and relax.
Once you relax,
everything's more clear.
Once you clear, then
you give action.
Then each your actions make
all different, I think.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a question, though,
how about when other
people try to change us?
How do we react to
[INAUDIBLE] as the people want
to change us?
Let's say my wife want to change
me and it's making me stressed.
Then how I handle this case?
TULKU LOBSANG: OK, I think then
you send your wife with me,
and I talk.
I'm just joking.
I'm sorry.
That's always very--
is a challenge.
We have some kind of
a story, a saying.
One day they have the
story of the mother
and the wife is fighting.
Mother and the wife is fighting.
And my mother and
my wife is fighting.
My wife always say
your mother is no good.
And then, my mother say
always your wife is not good.
And in between, I'm suffering.
And then, always my mother
say your wife is not good.
But I know my wife is
not complete not good.
And I always try to explain.
Then my mother fight more.
And then my wife says
my mother is not good.
And then I know it's
not everything, too.
Then I try to always
talk something.
And then, my wife is more fight.
That's means we all
have more fight.
Then solution, when
your wife say--
I'm giving a round answer.
The solution, your wife say your
mother is no good many things
and the best you be silence.
You say, OK, You say,
OK, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Why?
Because the truth
is not important.
Help is more important.
Truth is not-- because
truth is not fixable.
Truth is not important.
Help is more important.
We have a saying.
Therefore, my wife
say my mother no good.
It's not true, but
the best I say yes.
Yes.
I don't need to give reason.
I say yes and yes.
And my mother say
your wife is not good.
Then I also say yes and yes.
I say OK, OK, OK.
Then she less talk,
less talk hopefully.
And then one day maybe
you all come one table.
Then they both start to talk.
And the best you be
head down and don't
say anything and silence.
We say something look like this.
Therefore, I don't have
a really perfect answer.
Just I give an example.
Yes, I don't have a really,
really perfect answer,
some quick answers there.
Therefore, truth
is not important.
Help is more important.
Truth is not important.
Help is important.
Because truth is not flexible.
Therefore, you need
to be flexible.
Therefore, more help, then
you need to say yes, yes.
It's OK.
Be flexible.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TULKU LOBSANG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TULKU LOBSANG: Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Are you
relaxed all the time?
TULKU LOBSANG: Me, no,
no, not all the time.
No, I'm more relaxed.
I say yes.
I relax generally,
but not always.
But generally, I quite relax.
But not some time.
Sometimes not.
But generally, I have
a very clear decision.
I have a very, very
clear decision.
That's help me.
I have one general,
clear decision.
I need some time every
day some decisions,
but I have a very clear
picture and a clear understand,
and this maybe me
help generally calm.
But sometimes small
things make me a problem.
Something big thing
happen, I'm always calm.
But very small things
happen and maybe you--
I don't know-- you say bring
food in the 10:00 and you five
minutes late sometime those--
the very very small things.
Therefore, I need more
careful the small things.
The big things.
I'm already exercised,
training myself.
Any big problems coming,
I'm more relaxed, more calm.
But the small, very small
problems, I'm sometimes--
and that sometimes
makes me bothered.
Therefore, I need more training
with the small problems
to also make a calm,
not only big problems.
Therefore generally, I
feel little more calm.
OK?
AUDIENCE: I was curious
if you had any tips.
I think I find myself suffering
from that subtle laziness
that you were talking about.
How can you escape that
trap of being subtly lazy?
Is it through relaxation,
meditation, or do
you have any specific
advice about how to become--
TULKU LOBSANG: The laziness,
they have many antidotes.
But most important
laziness antidote
is motivation and believe.
Believe and motivation is
the antidote of the laziness.
But we always say I need
a reason to motivate.
I need a reason.
I need the reason.
I need a reason to motivate.
My reason is too small.
And my motivation is too small.
My motivation is too small.
My belief is too small.
My practice too small.
Therefore, you need reason.
When you want bigger reason,
you need to big understand.
You more understand, you really
understand, you have a reason.
You have a more reason,
and you're motivated.
You're motivated,
you'll believe.
You believe, you practice.
You practice and
you become success.
Therefore, I think, I'm
sure relaxation always good.
Wherever you have
laziness, I think
first you need to go to deeper
yourself, make a discussion
yourself.
And you need to find
a big, big reason--
you need a big reason to
find that to motivate.
Reason is motivate.
Sometimes our
reason is too small.
I say why you meditate?
Oh, I think, I don't know.
Some people say good.
Therefore, I come here.
You see, your
reason is so small.
And clear you don't
practice this two time,
three time, you never do.
Why?
And I say why, you need
to give big reason.
To reason, you
need to understand.
You more understand, hopefully,
you have more reason.
You have more reason.
And the reason is the power.
And that's make real motivate.
Something look like this.
Therefore, maybe go to
retreat, two, three day.
And to make discussion yourself.
You don't reject it all
kind of mind and just you
make every mind,
all kind of mind,
let's make invite to
make come, and speak,
and to discuss, and to
make big meeting yourself.
And then, maybe
you come together.
You have some-- then you
make one conclusion possible
yourself.
Because the laziness
is a big problem.
And you lose believe yourself.
Once you're lazy--
Example, today I give you
a new mind, let's say.
I talk.
I'm not a good talker,
but when I'm talk
maybe you have a new mind.
You come more exciting OK,
maybe I'll do this way.
That is good.
But then the other mind
start to saying you,
yes, you you always say I
do, but you never did it.
I don't believe you.
And then you go down.
You see, you always
try to motivate,
but the deep mind, mind who
stay with you last 25 years,
he always don't believe you.
Because 25 years you
always promise yourself,
but you never did it.
Yes, but then new mind.
You go to somewhere.
Somebody talk so many thing.
New mind born.
He say, yes, I want to do now.
And this old mind
say hey, you know,
better you don't so exciting.
I know this man.
25 years, but he never do.
And then, again, you--
you see?
Therefore, I think make
big [INAUDIBLE] yourself.
Make deep look inside to
make a discussion yourself
to bring one big reason.
Reason is a power.
And that's make motivation.
OK, thank you very much.